This episode is made possible by dashlane secure your data from prying eyes by signing up for a free account today
For almost the entirety of human history, we've always had a bit of a thing for predicting the future. Sometimes we get pretty close and
Sometimes we're way off
In this episode we're going to look at a few of the notable examples since the early 20th century when we really began to wonder
How modern and future technology would change our lives and the world
We'll start with one topic that people still love to theorize about today the future of cars
Back in the late 30s and 40s cars had officially become a staple of modern
society and as a relatively new technology people were always thinking up new ways to make them even better in the
1930s the predictions for the future of cars were pretty tame not many dreams of flying cars yet
The development of more complete streamlining for motor cars will be the problem of Engineers of tomorrow
Someday this problem will finally be solved sometime in the future. The completely streamlined torpedo car may come into use
Elevated highways wide and level may let us go 120 miles an hour
But such a torpedo car on our streets today would be entirely impractical
People simply expected the engineers of the future to design faster safer and more aerodynamic vehicles in that regard. They were absolutely right
After the war we saw films like this one from 1948
People were beginning to experiment more and we got to see some unusual
contraptions
Chariot can really run you around in circles. What's the trouble Gary?
Oh
Modern Frankenstein and here's another streamlined marvel on wheels. It only needs a pair of wings to be at home in the sky
Formidable indeed is its nose?
With riveted aluminum fuselage entry hatch and rugged and panache. It's wasting time on the ground
But being earthbound the monster is traveled out out of the highway to frighten other motivations
if you're looking for a 1960 model this may well be it a
Lot of these design elements seem kind of ridiculous to us now
incorporating airplane features and controls didn't really catch on mostly because it was
Unnecessary and complicated that being said we have seen a few three-wheeled cars
and
reversed three-wheeled car
Things and some of the aesthetic elements of late 40s concept cars have snuck into modern styling
For example, this one looks a lot like a current Rolls Royce concept in the mid 1950s
We really began to see some sci-fi ideas
Take shape flying cars hover cars and of course self-driving cars
the idea of self-driving cars isn't new but the
Implementation is very different
Instead of computers Manning the controls in this film the cars of the future were imagined to be guided by magnetic strips in the road
with a bit of information from control towers and the driver power to Firebird to tower to Firebird to
all traffic moving in normal pattern
Fb-22 tower we're heading for Chicago. Please route us through over
Well done Firebird - you're now under automatic control hands off steering
Here we go on the high speed safety lane
Ah
They
Comfortable my probes are as different as self-driving cars look today
They are catching on and it looks like these predictions while several decades off are actually pretty accurate at least at surface level
Besides cars, we've always been fascinated with how the people of the future might live. What will their homes look like?
What amazing new technologies will they have at their disposal? What will the fashion look like?
The people of the 1920s had some interesting ideas when it came to clothing most famous fashion designers in the u.s
Today have been asked to forecast what Eve will look like in AD 2000
One idea is a dress that can be adapted for morning afternoon or evening. It's the sleeves. What does it?
Apparently in AD 2000 we shall be having a hair-raising time
Yet another designer goes so far as to believe that skirts will disappear entirely
Shoes will have cantilever heels and an electric belt will adapt the body to climatic changes
The likely clared woman of tomorrow, ooh swish will move in an atmosphere that scientifically kept at the right temperature the
future bride in a wedding dress of glass what the grumble we're apart from a worid look isn't mentioned a
dress of aluminium with a sash to change it for afternoon or evening an
Electric headlight to help her to find an honest man as for him if he matters at all
He'll be fitted with a telephone a radio and containers for coins keys and candy for cutie
In some ways they were right dresses have lost some ground to pants shorts and skirts
But they're still very much a part of modern clothing and in some ways they were hilariously wrong light bulb head
Where a chest-mounted phone they were at least correct in assuming we'd have phones with us pretty much all the time
Kitchens maybe the thing that's changed the least since these predictions from the 50s
But it's interesting to see what people expected and how societal norms have changed
Press button dream coming true for mrs. Housewife
All sorts of wonders are hers at the push of a button from refrigerator doors to countertops built for big gals or little gals
Don't have to lean over here you see?
What's for dinner consult the menus on pictures and dish up something new for a change
hummingbird wings on toast maybe and look where the toaster is a
Wave of the hand and presto down comes a hidden cabinet with the dishes
Mama will feel like a fairy princess with a magic wand in a place like this
We won't be able to get her out of the kitchen
but we'll cross that bridge when we get to it right now the question before the house is what's cooking and
when you eat
The interesting thing about this particular film is that all of these changes are completely unnecessary and would definitely slow you down in the kitchen
The closest thing to being accurate from this film is probably the video screen recipes
It's not something that's built into modern kitchens
but we do often use phones or tablets instead of cookbooks to find recipes as
We entered the 60s and saw the advent of computer technology people began to really consider what these new machines could do in the future
This is the point in history where our prediction started to align more with reality except for our weird fascination with truly useless robots
Here we see a woman
ordering a giant slow lumbering robot to do menial tasks such as open the door or light a candle all of these things could have
been accomplished much more quickly without the Robo Butler but when you think about it
We actually do have some machines that do our bidding
They may not be seven-foot-tall abominations, but we can order them to play music
Give us the weather or change the lighting and of course the fascination with humanoid robots never really went away
We're still working on creating them, but we're more interested in the artificial intelligence aspect than having a mechanical servant to do our chores
besides the nightmarish slave robots that thankfully never came to be some predictions from the 60s ended up very close to reality for example this
Film from the early 60s explains how children will do the majority of their learning through computers
Master James sure eight years old
student
attends formal school two morning's a week
Much of his education. However is carried on in a kind of education center within the home and
Fed into teaching machines which allow him to progress as rapidly as his Awakening mind can absorb the audiovisual lessons
They did guess that this would be the norm by the year 1999 so they weren't exactly right in that regard
But they were pretty close
We did have educational games and programs by then
but we didn't really start to see proper web-based online classes for another several years this clip from
1961 shows a woman buying clothes from the comfort of her own home while looking at pictures of it on a digital screen
Sounds pretty familiar
Yellow I don't know do you have it in green certainly here it is
Yes, fine, that's it I'll take it please send it out to me here's my credit card
Oh, and don't forget the stripe pillowcases
No, we won't this prediction wasn't completely accurate as the woman is still interacting with another human on the phone
But ordering things from your own home device has become the backbone of 21st century shopping
Just six years after that prediction from 1961
We get this a much more accurate batch of predictions centered around the importance of so-called home video screens
Which clearly became modern desktop computers in this film. We see a woman buying clothes again
But this time there's no human interaction required later
We see the husband paying for the clothes accessing his bank account and sending electronic letters all from the home video screen system
paid for by the husband at his counterpart console all bills and transactions will be carried out electronically a
Central bank computer will debit the family's account the amount of purchases and credit the department store. For example
Informing the family's home computer at the same time
Father at the touch of a button receives an instantaneous printed copy of his budget the amount of taxes
He owes the payments left on the car and so forth
All documents and household records are available on the video screen for immediate reference
Also at his disposal is an electronic correspondence
Machine or home post office which allows for instant written communication between individuals anywhere in the world
While it may not be super refined this whole system is a very accurate representation of how we use modern computers
We shop online pay bills and view bank statements and send emails as the 60s drew to a close
We started seeing more reasonable predictions mostly because our understanding of computer technology
Allowed us to make more educated guesses in regards to further development. Of course
We never stopped making guesses about the future and even today we see some truly sci-fi predictions, but that's a topic for a future video
Now with all these advancements in computing technology
It stands to reason that the good people of the future will need a way to protect their valuable information from digital criminals
Consider for a moment the service that secures your personal information by way of automatically generated strings of letters numbers and symbols
Which the computer savvy call passwords?
This is a scale model of the home computer of the future with the magic of modern film
We can demonstrate how this futuristic
information security service will operate the average Joe of the future has a lot on his plate and
Doesn't want to remember all these different passwords and everyone knows one mustn't use the same password for everything with this new service
Let's call it - Lane. He doesn't have to the
Application a word used to describe future computer programs can be accessed on his home computer or handheld computing device
Which will be commonplace in the year 2018 he can rest easy knowing that even the most sophisticated computer criminal. Can't steal his information
Because - Lane is locally secured which means the passwords are only stored on his machines
If Joe everyman is inexperienced with home computers - Lane takes care of his security for him
Allowing even a simpleton to automatically change unsafe passwords
The program also allows users to store often used information
Like credit card numbers for digital shopping the electronic mail addresses and telephone numbers which can be used to automatically fill-in digital forms
Greatest minds predicted television programs and films will be widely available through entertainment
services on the computers of the future
Knowing this the secure sharing of passwords between friends and family who don't use these services will be a popular feature
allowing loved ones to catch up on season 100 of The Andy Griffith Show
Security peace of mind and convenience all of these features and more will be included in the best computer programs of the future
Now that prediction was accurate protect your passwords for free by downloading dashlane today as a special. Thanks for fans of second
thought you can get a 30-day free trial of dashlane premium plus 10% off your premium subscription by following the link below and using the
Code second. Thought it's available for Mac PC iOS and Android
So whether you up for the free or premium account, I can't recommend Ashley and highly enough
So to support the channel and secure your valuable data, check out - Lane at the link below